hey guys thanks for stopping by I
promise I won't take up too much of your
time I just wanted to talk about
something that was incredibly important
and not only to me but to every single
one of you everyone that's watching this
video right now is affected by what's
about to happen to the Internet and you
probably know about it already but
earlier today the FCC Chairman announced
a plan to repeal and draw back a lot of
net neutrality laws and kind of changed
the way that we access the Internet and
that sounds bad because it is bad and
I'll provide links in the description
not only to information other people
talking about it and ways for you to
fight back on this but also I just
wanted to mention why it was so
important because if some of you don't
know like net neutrality is simply a way
of saying that the Internet is open and
accessible to everybody you're able to
go wherever you want on the internet
you're able to do whatever you want on
the Internet you're able to have some
semblance of anonymity on the internet
without all the companies trying to
track your every movement and it's not
perfect but those are because of the net
neutrality laws that we have right now
now imagine if these things were to come
to pass you go to YouTube one day and
you find instead of your videos you find
this page that says we're sorry you
haven't paid for the entertainment
package of your internet plan please pay
five more dollars what they want is to
make the internet a more profitable
place and that sounds bad on its face
but that's also just the first step of
it like entertainment you may think like
ah that's okay like that's totally fine
but if you allow something like that to
happen then you put in the framework for
information to be controlled and when
you do that you control what people see
and when you do that you control what
people think and I'm not saying this is
gonna lead to a dystopian future where
everyone's mind controlled and doesn't
think for themselves but it does ruin a
lot of opportunities that people have to
be able to do what they want to do on
the Internet you start down the path
where this amazing thing that connects
every single human
the globe together and allows for the
free spread of information wherever it
wants to go you lock down opportunities
and ability for people to thrive both
for themselves and for our future
generations and I'm not even saying that
you shouldn't have to pay for the
Internet
I mean you still have to pay for water
but there's no just barely clean enough
water and then the premium water for
five dollars more that is actually not
gonna kill you but when you set up a
system that allows corners to be cut and
allows businesses to prioritize profit
over people
that's when society starts to degrade
and that's when innovation becomes
stifled because it's not profitable for
everyone to make leaps and bounds we as
a species are not defined by profit like
we're just better than that now I hope
we're better than I want to be better
than bottom line is the Internet should
be open and accessible to everybody
there shouldn't be pay walls that
control what you can see based on how
much money you make there shouldn't be
walls in general that control the
information that you see and there
shouldn't be people watching your every
move on the Internet we can't allow this
to happen and thankfully there are ways
to fight it in the description i
provided tons of links to not only
information about this that can explain
it better than I just did but also ways
that you can fight back where you can
contact people that are making these
decisions they're all done in the
description there's ways to contact your
Congressman your Senators your
government officials is ways to write to
the FCC like even if they want to ignore
even if they want profit
you can still make a difference these
systems are only in place because we
just decided it the internet only exists
because we decided to build it so we
have to take charge and remember that
this is so important that we need to
protect it because the Internet's a
beautiful thing because of how open and
accessible it is and I want to keep it
that way I want you guys to be able to
enjoy whatever you want to enjoy I want
you guys to be able to do what you want
to do on the internet without someone
telling you that you can't that's all
I'll say for now thank you everybody so
much for watching if you can please take
the time to try to make a difference all
the links are down in the description
there's tons of other people talking
about it right now and it's incredibly
important so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye